but for everyone else ball movement ball
movement get others involved kill gumpa
step at the pass picked off chained up
for brown on the drive already you could
tell you want to play with them you see
how you threw that ball up to Decker he
doesn't have to get some smack and close
to the rim signed as a free agent
so quite a bit of action reddit cop the
screen will take it inside the last line
of defense has always been for the
Celtics Al Horford each team shoots
about 35 percent smart finds Horford who
began to fire down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
things will slam it in lost 117 116 is
illness valentinus checks it count it
and a foul game playing gets Offerman
when he's at the five you talk about a
format
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
arson gets a new clock Morford windmills
off the dribble
Foundry just 3/4 and more just pick up
his fourth foul yeah closing on Horford
shooting the ball on the offensive end
foul committed by Marcus smart Austin
finding some rhythm on the Skip back
[Applause]
Horford good fate takes it to the basket
there's that there's another example of
wide-open space eat smart forage in the
basket
with his own pick-and-roll action those
special player his ability to create
good shots late the game nice defense by
Kyrie
nice play by Kyra you find it to get
back to the play get him mr. first win
often olifant passes up the shot forced
to take it off with runner and banks it
home that was sweet pretty from the top
Jalen Brown to the rim
extra pass up to Al there's the shot he
was gonna pass it gets boughs and one
[Music]
over and up therefore the defensive play
look or not that's the basketball throws
it up hands chance for three-point play
let's play by Jason Tatum just out there
playing ball game look at the aggressive
roll by our what that does sit defense
there's the chance to finish there's he
had one they still ranked in the bottom
third and offensive efficiency Hayward
on the delivery to Horford for the flush
a nice pick-and-roll pocket pass Hayward
to Horford good start by Boston Crowder
blocked by Horford here's Brown on the
break been over five minutes since the
sellers have made a field goal no good
block by Horford picked off by smart
Tatum to school at the last 12 for the
Celtics up top Horford gets to good play
by Kyrie hitting over the top of the
screen into the paint second three of
the game they go inside Carter realizes
what he has been ejected by
take a look at this good block on the
spin there is al horford right ready and
willing to block that shot Horford
follow away jumper for two
that's al horford bit tool nice little
crossover move going to get into the
lane oh my forfeit there's a big time
block
[Applause]
little crossover here
[Music]
is difficult to do but synthesis a team
have two offensive rebounds
there you go allocates back with the
ball celtics get back one d pelicans
another turnover
Kyrie cracks it down
consumes but we could be good if we
speed up the game how rollin that right
hand gets it to go
and one potato
[Applause]
and right now boo York can't guard that
funeral action one of the reasons that
we think did click to smart as a starter
[Applause]
Rozier throwing a Napa traffic this time
pay that much to put a move on
containable spin-off pass water plays he
set it up for Horford
[Applause]
you can tell as this game has progressed
Tucson a 25 hit it
Irving gets it back to ball spread hope
and good look underneath to smart
hesitates gets to it and foul for free
finds Tyrese hope it gets it back puts
it on the court takes it to the basket
on it and a foul three gets out some
momentum to go sit tomorrow's Irving's
in the paint swallowed up Horford the
dream you can't tell me he can flex now
takes it under 40 seconds gets it back
Horford for three good night you know
they say he gets all the 50/50 balls I
would say he gets the 80/20 ball when
you have an 80% chance to get it he's
got a 20 interesting point towns with
the mid-range jump shot I know you're
sitting there oh he didn't just say
people will tell you that Al Horford is
sort of the hub of they're often on some
candy over there you know you have to
wait and see the additions
the additions to buy out market and back
comes Marcus smart who's also back in
the lineup you missed the previous game
due to illness Horford with an easy one
at the rim
Boston's got a 5 on pour the other way
Hayward Hartford with a little bit of
smoke
in control here the law Horford
Jackson trying to defend it right now
[Applause]
cachito kinds of trees
at 68 Johnson coming to the ball picked
off second pass Johnson's thrown away
Kyrie inside Horford good spot gets to
authorities four points three boards
couple of assists Thompson triple teams
out of his hands Irving for three
well they had a good defensive strip and
stop a good push by smart and then the
nice simple pass on by klay Thompson
shot clock winding down wolfertz got to
get it up just gets it off the time nine
points for Horford it's back to three
Morris jumper curry chips uprights Al
Horford put a go to pass
[Music]
picked off by Tatum - one second on the
shot clock Tatum to the basket to tune
picks out my potato horses classic otter
it's loud it's too steady time
they're mostly guys out there cutting
and slashing from the weak side the tube
comes out sets the screen gets the ball
back in the corner with ten on the shot
clock
gets it ahead too smart throws it up
tomorrow's round in the right spot
Youngstown of course or further back
down patiently going to work you can
feel that coming easy to for Horford I'd
say yeah he plays like an old man but
he's so good at it back for wide open L
Horford three oh good job there by
Horford to get it out and boy hey I've
just done the number defensively
[Music]
well that was a much-needed basket my
whole first cut would either no and then
allergist using his quickness night to
make sure we keep starting with the
right purpose and getting those shots
that we got Thank You Pat Snickers Dahle
moments ago there's a Horford feet array
[Applause]
he kept that to drop ties the game at 95
teams making plays down the stretch
Kyrie Al Horford high screen and roll
two players go to Kyrie who knocks their
back to Horford back to Kyrie back to
Horford easy two
[Music]
get this good play coming up offered and
Kairi back into the paint heads Portis
they're gonna move to stopping the
penetration is Bogdanovich hate him off
the curl kick out - out out one dribble
jump shot packet it at the button how
about that patience Celtics maintaining
a five-point lead smart up hideout
Horford and the foul great play look
little misdirection over the top throws
it down on his former teammate I know he
won two championships together now with
the mismatch taking his time buddy hield
Tufte whistled for the foul count the
bucket
the Miller Lite hold true moment against
mr. bunny healed himself to lead back up
to 14 for the Clippers here's out
putting it on a debt one right as you
bunch yeah L got a dominate that matchup
scramblers for the loose ball keeps it
alive to halt identities Williams yeah
look at this hustle by Hayward
[Music]
that up fake Irving
[Music]
picks up his 11th assist yeah
cauley-stein got stymie look at this
nice play by Kyrie Thrones cauley-stein
why do I do
no bulldog keep this to player to make
the stops
Irving back to Horford Horford for three
ties the game we ballin' Horford came up
with the loose ball thank god basket out
of it for free
off the feed from smart we haven't seen
and awhile bades open misses the shot
rebound controlled by Horford South's
get a second opportunity over the top
made by Kyrie
nice pass good look by harford 1s sit no
screens and then get within 15 feet
shoot the grumpus
Horford quiz head down a foul
it's not thinking about block it out
blocking shots out of IO is on those
passes of this heat people were talking
about it's turned over off the court
Tatum portrait for - nicely done take a
look at this come up with the steal
watch Kyrie here behind the back that
gets him going to on one and Kelly
Olynyk over to district side like he was
second cévennes wanna bend and knees out
on a perimeter one little head fake and
it was by Austin against young Walker
they let her down he was doing client
but then they weren't winning including
the pack now he's just got to get back
to how he played at the beginning off
event Joseph turns it over
Kyrie Irving leading the break ahead
timorous bars cuts up and under backs at
home Rozier 12 on the shot clock
morphix working on birch to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there comes brown footways at Carlson
and said it goes tailor
mythicality has shown up for the Boston
Celtics here in this fourth quarter
beautiful block shot once he makes that
move now help out all right Horford is
excellent in finding space Yanis blocked
by Horford always sent it back flying
over the points in everything else just
mike says he lets them get a half ahead
of them and then suddenly he's nobody
contact on the hip see that great point
because you can see he definitely
demonstrated it right there Al Horford
with a counterfeit downtown what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content